voici un parfum solide comme on
pratiquait la renaissance c'est à dire
on utilisait des produits à base de cire
d'huile parfumée et on se parfumer comme
ça on mettait son doigt et puis un jour
on voulait ce parfum c'est celui de la
reine margot une fragrance composé
dambre de musc de jasmin que nicola de
bari a pu reconstituer grâce au carnet
de comptabilité de la cour
elle utilisait les matières premières et
ensuite les mélanger ça donnait une pâte
et donc ça donnait un parfum solide
qu'est ce que ça reflète de la
personnalité de la reine margot la
sensualité
parce que on est dans un parfum
extrêmement sensuelle extrêmement
puissant et le goût pour les choses
originales et personnelles parce que
elle faisait elle-même son parfum c'est
son choix s'est fait à la maison période
de renouveau artistique et
architecturale la renaissance a permis
des innovations sans précédent dans la
parfumerie l'ouverture de nouvelles
routes commerciales
il fut pour beaucoup on va chercher les
matières premières en asie directement
on ne passe plus par venise on ne parle
plus par le sultan de de turquie on va
directement donc ça c'est ça amène
beaucoup plus de matière première et à
des prix plus accessibles
encore que très cher et puis il ya la
découverte par les arabes de l'alcool et
donc on va commencer à utiliser l'alcool
en parfumerie à partir de la renaissance
de ces nouveautés l'astrologue
l'apothicaire nostradamus saisie en 15
155 et rédige un traité des phares de
man dans lequel nicolas de bari a puisé
une recette composé d'ingrédients ultra
moderne à l'époque les oranje qui arrive
à la cour de france à l'époque de la
renaissance
ce sont des produits de luxe dont qui
met dans le parfum des zestes d'orange
et ce faisant c'est comme s'ils
mettaient des louches de caviar dans un
plat c'est le fin du fin c'est le chic
du chic
une senteur très en cour que la future
reine margot est certainement le
privilège du met
alors qu'elle n'était qu'une enfant
[Musique]